mes chers collègues je vous propose de
commencer cette audition parce que comme
sommes retransmis voilà aa
messieurs cadets que de râler comme un
bon breton
[Rires]
c'est bon tout le monde et est prêt très
bien madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous accueillons ce matin
madame emmanuelle wargon que nous
connaissons voilà que nous connaissons
bien pour avoir travaillé avec vous
madame la ministre dans le dernier
quinquennat qui est donc la candidate a
proposé par le président de la
république à la fonction de présidente
du collège de la commission de
régulation de l'énergie la cre eux en
application je le répète à chaque fois
mais c'est très important d'avoir en
tête en application de cinquième alinéa
de l'article 13 de la constitution
cette nomination par décret du président
de la république ne peut intervenir
qu'après audition par les commissions
compétentes de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat cette audition est ouverte à la
presse et au public que je salue et
retransmise sur le site du sénat elle
donnera lieu à un vote à bulletins
secrets pour lequel les délégations de
vote ne sont pas autorisés
l'assemblée nationale devant entendre
madame wargon à 11 heures après le sénat
nous dépouilleront les bulletins d'ici
la mi journée il ne pourra être procédé
à cette nomination si l'addition des
votes négatifs dans les deux commissions
représente au moins trois cinquièmes des
suffrages exprimés
pardon avant de passer la parole à notre
collègue patrick chauvel j'ai perdu
voilà qui est là patrick chever
rapporteur sur cette nomination puis à
notre collègue daniel grémillet
président du groupe d'études énergie je
souhaiterais rappeler le très grand
intérêt que notre commission et je
dirais que le sénat d'une façon générale
porte à la régulation des marchés de
l'énergie
lundi encore lors de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi pouvoir
d'achat nous avons fait aboutir de
belles avancées en la matière en
confortant la régulation de l'énergie
nucléaire par le plafonnement de la
reine nous avons favorisé l'essor des
énergies renouvelables
simplifiant par exemple les procédures
pour le biogaz et nous avons conçu
consolider la protection des
consommateurs en renforçant
l'information et en encadrant les
coupures
jamais peut-être madame la ministre une
telle nomination à une autorité
indépendante comme la creuse n'aura été
réalisée dans un contexte aussi sensible
pour notre pays pour l'europe et dans un
contexte géopolitique
climatique incertain est extrêmement
complexe l'énergie c'est la vie et nous
sommes aujourd'hui en raison de choix
passés dans une situation extrêmement
critique qui nécessitent l'éclairage de
ces j'ose dire d'une commission de
régulation d'énergie absolument
pertinente est absolument éclairée elle
aussi
sur sur les questions d'énergie donc je
vais laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur puis au président de la
commission du groupe d'études mais je
voudrais vous dire que vraiment dans
cette période critique la vision de la
creux qui éclaire l'exécutif est
vraiment une chose extrêmement
importante à laquelle nous attachons
nous attachons beaucoup beaucoup
d'attention et nous serons donc très
intéressé pour voir quelle est votre
vision de la creux quelle est votre
vision du marché de l'énergie et comment
vous estimez devoir exercer votre rôle
en relation avec bien sûr l'exécutif
mais aussi avec le parlement voilà
patrick chauvet rapporteur merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre vous
avez vous est conseillé remettre à la
cour des comptes et avait fait une
partie de votre carrière au sein de
ministères ou d'établissements sociaux
vous avez également exercé les fonctions
ministérielles que nous connaissons tous
en tant que secrétaire d'état à la
transition écologique de 2018 à 2020
puis ministre délégué au logement de
2020 à 2022 la première interrogation
est donc qu'est ce qui vous motive à
vous investir dans un secteur celui de
l'énergie
différents de ceux dans lesquels vous
avez évolué auparavant d'autre part
comment entendez vous garantir
l'indépendance de la creuse qui est une
autorité administrative indépendante
compte tenu de vos anciennes fonctions
ministérielles devrait vous vous déporté
sur les sujets dont vous auriez eu à
connaître dans ses anciennes fonctions
je pense par exemple à la rénovation
énergétique proche des missions de la
creuse créée par la loi du 10 février
2000 le service public de l'électricité
la creux a pour principale mission de
concourir au bon fonctionnement des
marchés de l'électricité et du gaz
naturel au bénéfice des consommateurs
finals et en cohérence avec les
objectifs de la politique énergétique
ma deuxième interrogation concerne donc
les missions de la creuse dans le
contexte de crise énergétique
le rôle des autorités de régulation va
croître le paquet a justement à
l'objectif 55 complété par le plan riz
power européen fils fixe des exigences
en matière d'énergies renouvelables
d'hydrogène d'électromobilité de réseau
ou de stockage les plans de résilience
et d'investissement prévoit des montants
importants s'agissant de l'énergie
nucléaire de l'hydrogène ou de lait trop
mobilité ce cadre a des répercussions
sur les missions de la creux ou leurs
conditions d'exercice comment la creux
les appréhende telle et telle en
capacité d'y faire face sur les plans
budgétaires et humains
ma troisième interrogation concerne la
crise énergétique et les moyens mis en
oeuvre pour y faire face quelle
appréciation portez vous sur le bouclier
tarifaire partagez vous le principe du
relèvement de 21 térawattheures de la
reine qui conduit à un transfert de 10
milliards de recettes du groupe edf vers
les consommateurs
de plus comment conjuguer les lacunes de
ce bouclier
comment mieux protéger les consommateurs
qui ne bénéficient pas des tarifs
réglementés de vente à combien s'élève
le rattrapage en 2023 du blocage
tarifaires sur les consommateurs enfin
comment anticipez-vous la fin des tarifs
réglementés de vente en gaz prévue pour
juillet 2023
ma dernière interrogation a trait à
l'avenir du secteur de l'énergie en
pleine effervescence
à l'échelle européenne quelle est votre
position sur la réforme du marché de
l'électricité
êtes vous favorable à la suppression du
principe du coût marginal qui lie le
prix de l'électricité à celui du gaz à
l'échelle nationale capable quelle
appréciation portez vous sur la relance
de l'énergie nucléaire pour le nucléaire
existant quels mécanismes de régulation
devrait remplacer la reine et que
faut-il envisager pour le nouveau
nucléaire une garantie de prix comme au
royaume uni à consortium d'électro
intensif comme en finlande un
financement étatique comme en république
tchèque voilà les questions en vous
remerciant par avance des réponses que
vous pourrez y apporter madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président du groupe d'études énergie
services
merci madame présente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
madame la ministre je ne compléterait
que marginalement les questions de notre
président de notre rapporteur
le premier point concerne l'essor des
énergies renouvelables
le ministère de la transition
énergétique a annoncé un plan modifiant
les dispositifs de soutien budgétaires
sont prévues la suspension de la baisse
des tarifs sur le photovoltaïque le
relèvement des coûts prises en compte
dans les appels d'offres d'extension du
délai ou du périmètre de certains appels
d'offres ou encore l'autorisation de
vente de l'énergie sur les marchés pour
certains lauréats quel est votre avis
sur ces annonces plus largement pensez
vous qu'il faille consolidé dispositifs
de soutien publics pour maximiser les
projets ou au contraire en modérer le
coût qui s'élève déjà à 5 milliard
d'euros par an faut-il préférer des
dispositifs de soutien extra budgétaires
tels que les rabais tarifaires des
garanties d'origine ou les contrats de
gré à gré par ailleurs le stockage
indispensable pour pallier
l'intermittence
des énergies renouvelables est il assez
soutenu enfin l'autoconsommation porter
d'externalités positives pour les
consommateurs mais négatives pour les
réseaux doit-elle être encouragé le
deuxième point
a trait à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
la crue a récemment publié un rapport
sur les anticipations des acteurs du
marché de l'électricité indiquant que
ces derniers prévoient une attente du
plafond du prix sur les enchères de 200
heures par trimestre ce qui reflèterait
donc la crainte des marchés quant au
risque d'un déséquilibre offre demande
pouvez vous préciser cette année
presque ton une rupture sur le plan de
l'approvisionnement 15 en raison de la
guerre en ukraine où on a existé compte
tenu du phénomène de corrosion sous
contrainte les dispositifs de stockage
d'arrêter d'intérêt plus vite et
d'effacement fonctionne-t-il assez à
votre avis et comment favoriser l'
effort de sobriété énergétique
identifiez vous des gisements tant chez
les professionnels que chez les
particuliers
mondiale ni un point porte sur
l'évolution de notre mix énergétique
le législateur aura à se prononcer à
l'occasion de la loi quinquennale sur
l'énergie de 2023 notre commission un
résolument plaidé pour faire du scénario
n 03 de rte un minimum à atteindre
appelant à construire rapidement et
concrètement c'est pas 6 mai 14 e p r
quel est votre point de vue sur le mix
énergétique idéal
merci merci vous pour tous les deux je
voulais c'est la parole
madame d'argon pour voilà répondent aux
questions mais aussi présentés
globalement votre candidature et la
vision vous avez de ce cette mission
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président du groupe d'études mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices je
suis très heureuse très honoré même
d'être devant vous aujourd'hui pour
présenter ma candidature à la tête de la
creux institutions tellement importante
dans cette période et ce conformément
vous l'avez rappelé madame la présidente
à la procédure de l'article 13 de la
constitution
je vais commencer par me présenter puis
j'évoquerai à la fois les grands enjeux
énergétiques et du coup elle la manière
dont la crue peut y répondre et les
priorités qui pourrait être là n si ma
candidature est retenue je vais
commencer par me présenter parce que
nous avons travaillé ensemble bien sûr
de nombreuses reprises mais en fait
l'essentiel de ma carrière est une
carrière administrative vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur je suis
conseillère maître à la cour des comptes
et j'ai passé 20 ans dans différentes
fonctions administratives dans des
administrations centrales et dans des
établissements publics j'ai eu
l'occasion de diriger des
administrations j'étais secrétaire
général des ministères sociaux j'étais
délégué général à l'emploi et à la
formation professionnelle avec environ
200 agents et puis j'ai été dans des
institutions indépendantes la cour des
comptes que vous avez cités qui m'a
formé où je suis conseillère maître et
l' agence du médicament où j'ai passé
quatre ans et c'est aussi une agence
indépendante qui prend ses décisions par
elle même indépendamment de la volonté
du gouvernement
ensuite j'ai ouvert une page politique
qui se referme aujourd'hui ses sept
nominations abouti cette page politique
m'a conduite à être secrétaire d'état à
l'écologie je suis ministre délégué au
logement
à cette occasion nous avons eu
l'occasion beaucoup de travailler
ensemble madame la présidente
et je vois beaucoup de sénatrices et
sénateurs avec lesquels j'ai beaucoup
travaillé y compris sur des sujets sur
lesquels nous avons réussi à obtenir des
accords et des formes de consensus et de
compromis je pense par exemple à la
création de l'office français de la
biodiversité
je suis aux lois 3ds et climat et
résilience mais pendant toutes ces
fonctions ministérielles
l'énergie a en réalité été au coeur de
beaucoup de dossiers que j'ai traité et
ce sont ces quatre années qui finalement
ont beaucoup tourné autour de l'énergie
qui m'amène aujourd'hui à cette
candidature à la commission de
régulation de l'énergie parce que j'ai
pris conscience à cette occasion en
travaillant ces différents dossiers de
l'importance absolument stratégique
quelle énergie pour notre pays beaucoup
d'énergie donc dans les dossiers que
j'ai traité en tant que secrétaire
d'état j'ai par exemple piloter déjà à
l'époque des groupes de travail pour
lever les freins réglementaires au
développement des énergies renouvelables
notamment sur les réseaux de chaleur
mais aussi sur l'éolien et sur le
solaire
au titre de mes fonctions de ministre
délégué au logement j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments avec ma prime rénové aussi
le soutien à la rénovation des bâtiments
publics et des bâtiments des
collectivités territoriales
j'ai donc pu toucher du doigt à quel
point l'énergie est essentiel pour notre
pays et je pense que c'est une très très
belle manière de servir le pays que
d'avoir l'opportunité d'être à la tête
de ce régulateur
sur ces enjeux énergétiques
il me semble qu'ils sont au nombre de
trois je voudrais commencer par la
sécurité d'approvisionnement et la
souveraineté énergétique
nous étions déjà je crois tous
convaincus de cette importance avant la
crise crise de l'énergie crise du crédit
yen mais nous voyons maintenant
aujourd'hui à quel point cette sécurité
d'approvisionnement et cette
souveraineté sont cruciaux pour le pays
le deuxième enjeu c'est bien sûr la
protection des consommateurs et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises la créa
rôle important sur la régulation des
marchés aux bénéfices non seulement du
consommateur individuel des ménages mais
aussi au bénéfice de toutes nos
entreprises que ce soit les industriels
électro intensifs où que ce soit les
entreprises en général
l'énergie est une partie importante des
charges qui pèsent sur les ménages une
partie importante de l'inflation
aujourd'hui et ce sont nos mesures de
régulation classique avec les tarifs
réglementés et la reine qui nous
permette en partie de protéger les
ménages et puis les mesures
exceptionnelles prises avec les
boucliers et pour les entreprises la
compétitivité est indispensable et puis
bien sûr le troisième enjeu peut être le
principal c'est l'accélération de la
transition écologique et nous savons que
nous avons des objectifs extrêmement
ambitieux vous l'avez rappelé à la fois
des objectifs nationaux des objectifs
communautaires qui vont nous amener un
double mouvement la baisse de notre
consommation d'énergie fixé à 40% pour
l'instant d'ici à 2050 et une part
croissante d'électricité dans notre mix
énergétique pour aller vers une énergie
décarbonée et les différents scénarii
dont celui que vous avez cités sont des
scénarii qui mène une augmentation en
valeur absolue de la production
énergétique
je voudrais dire à cette occasion que
pour atteindre tous ces objectifs
nous devons travailler sur la sobriété
et l'efficacité
sur le développement des énergies
renouvelables et sur l'appui sur le
nucléaire
sur l'efficacité et la sobriété
l'efficacité c'est vraiment l'idée
d'arriver au même résultat avec moins de
sources et de consommation d'énergie la
sobriété c'est aussi l'idée de changer
nos usages pour être essayer de moins
consommer d'énergie et trouver des
alternatives
c'est indispensable ne fait partie des
objectifs de politique publique que je
pense qu'il faut soutenir ensuite le
développement des énergies renouvelables
bien sûr nous savons que nous avons
encore de la marge encore besoin
d'énergie renouvelable supplémentaires
d'août où les travaux qui ont été faits
et encore récemment dans les textes que
vous venez d'adopter sur le nucléaire je
voudrais vraiment préciser ma position
qui je pense est un point très important
de la discussion je suis favorable à
l'électricité nucléaire
clairement je suis favorable à cette
électricité j'y suis favorable à la fois
sur le maintien des réacteurs existants
et sur le développement du nouveau
nucléaire
c'est un des éléments très importants du
design de marché j'y reviendrai que de
permettre à notre opérateur national de
soutenir le nucléaire existant et le
nouveau mais clair
quand j'ai été nommé secrétaire d'état
en octobre 2018 parmi les dossiers que
j'ai traité j'ai été amené à accompagner
les territoires à la fois pour la
fermeture des centrales à charbon et
pour la fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim donc je voudrais vraiment
être clair sur ce point là à ce moment
là on était déjà début 2019 la décision
de fermeture de fessenheim avaient été
prises longtemps auparavant
reconfirmer et à ce moment là en accord
avec la sncf n'avait pas lancé les
opérations de maintenance lourde et
visite décennale qui aura été dans le
calendrier normal de la centrale à ce
moment là la gestion du dossier
consistait à accompagner edf
techniquement et économiquement et
surtout accompagner le territoire qu'ils
étaient confrontés à une décision qui
étaient prises mais qui n'était pas
accompagnée notamment pour le projet de
territoire sur le technocentre et sur le
développement
d'industrie alternative au moment de la
décision de la fermeture de fessenheim
nous vivions sous l'hypothèse que la
consommation d'électricité seraient
stables voire en légère décroissance
cette hypothèse n'est pas exact ça n'est
plus l'hypothèse aujourd'hui et il est
clair que le monde a changé et que les
décisions doivent changer donc je vous
le dis clairement et sincèrement et
c'est ma position personnelle je
soutiendrai à la fois le maintien des
réacteurs existants bien sûr dans les
conditions de sécurité qui seront posées
par l'asn et le développement du nouveau
nucléaire qui est indispensable
quelles que soient les scénarii retenus
ces questions là ne sont pas d'abord du
ressort de la creuse elles sont de votre
ressort elles sont du ressort du
législateur vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le rapporteur la loi ppe qui va arriver
il a été prévu qui arrivera avant le 1er
juillet 2023 sera l'occasion pour le
législateur de définir la politique
énergétique du pays et quand on regarde
les textes de la creuse on s'aperçoit
que la mission de cette commission de
régulation de l'énergie
c'est de réguler les marchés et de
protéger le consommateur dans le respect
des orientations de politique
énergétique du pays et c'est dans ce
cadre que aura lieu l'action du
régulateur
vous m'avez posé la question de
l'indépendance c'est une question
extrêmement importante sur laquelle je
voudrais également répondre
d'abord j'ai eu une longue carrière
administrative dont je vous le disais
tout à l'heure dans deux institutions la
cour des comptes et l' agence du
médicament dont la vocation est l
indépendance
ensuite j'ai tourné une page je me suis
engagé politiquement cet engagement
prend fin avec cette nomination j'ai été
élue conseillère régionale en ile de
france je démissionnerai de ce mandat et
je rentre dans une nouvelle étape de ma
carrière dans laquelle je souhaite
mettre mes compétences et mon dernier
mais mon énergie au service de ce
régulateur en toute liberté
il y a eu des précédents je voudrais
vous citer par exemple jean pierre
jouyet qui est passé de secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes a
président de l'autorité des marchés
financiers mais on a eu aussi d'autres
figures politiques qui ont exercé des
fonctions politiques puis des fonctions
d'autorité administrative indépendante
je pense à jacques toubon par exemple
comme médiateur de la république
et dont ces différents cas je pense
aussi à dominique versini dans ces
différents cas les fonctions est exercé
en toute indépendance donc je vous le
dis très sincèrement très solennellement
aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière dans
ses fonctions je reprends ma liberté ma
liberté de magistrate ma liberté sur la
base de ma carrière et de mes
convictions que je vous ai exposé sur le
modèle énergétique français pour être de
nouveau d'une manière différente au
service de mon pays
la crue est par ailleurs une très belle
institution créée en 2000 je voudrais
saluer ces trois présidents successifs
jean syrota philippe de ladoucette et
jean françois carenco qui en ont fait
une institution respectée tellement
respecté d'ailleurs que plus de 80
missions nouvelles lui ont été confiés
depuis sa création en 2000
et
elle est respectée grâce à la force de
sa présidence et de son collège il y à
un collège à la tête de la creux avec
quatre autres membres du collège que je
voudrais saluer pour la qualité de leurs
travaux elle est respectée aussi par la
qualité du travail de ses agents environ
160 agents et pour répondre à la
question sur les moyens
là creux a pour l'instant réussi de
façon très satisfaisante à répondre aux
missions qui lui sont confiées mais bien
sûr l'augmentation naturelle des
missions et le renforcement de son rôle
nécessitera un soutien budgétaire en
budget et en effectifs pour lui
permettre de jouer son rôle à plein j'en
viens maintenant à vos questions plus
précises et aux priorités de
l'institution elle même la première
priorité est autour de la régulation des
réseaux c'est une régulation extrêmement
importante nous avons la chance d'avoir
des réseaux de transport et de
distribution de gaz et d'électricité de
bonne qualité en france mais ces réseaux
ont devant eux le défi du développement
des énergies renouvelables et d'ailleurs
du nouveau nucléaire et donc d'une
nouveau raccordement de toutes ces
sources d'énergie c'est une trajectoire
d'investissement extrêmement importante
qu'il faut accompagner à travers le
turpe une première étape a été passé
l'année dernière avec la sortie du tueur
pts 6 mais bien sûr les investissements
sont devant nous ils sont considérables
le deuxième enjeu des réseaux c'est la
solitaire à la solidarité nationale et
la péréquation des réseaux jouent un
rôle très important pour l'égalité de
tous sur le territoire devant l'accès à
l'énergie à la fois en prix avec la
péréquation et en qualité de service et
aussi en qualité de discussion avec les
collectivités concédantes et les
collectivités organisatrices de la
distribution de l'électricité
j'y serai très attentive et puis le
troisième enjeu des réseaux c'est de
faciliter toutes les flexibilités de
faciliter le stockage de faciliter les
interconnexions dans des conditions qui
nous permettront de passer l'hiver qui
vient et les hivers suivants dans des
conditions les plus satisfaisantes la
deuxième mission prioritaire de la creux
c'est la régulation des marchés
régulation et surveillance des marchés
des tailles et des marchés de gros et je
crois que nous avons besoin d'une
réforme importante du mode de fixation
des prix et des marchés à l'échelle
européenne et à l'échelle française la
creuse joue déjà ce rôle elle surveille
les fournisseurs alternatifs et à droit
constant il me paraît extrêmement
important par exemple de vérifier que la
reine telle qu'elle a été distribué
répartie profite bien au client final et
pas aux fournisseurs alternatifs et donc
de rencontres de renforcer encore ses
contrôles
mais nous sentons bien que les
mécanismes de régulation qui
fonctionnait par temps calme que ce soit
à l'échelle française et européenne ne
fonctionne plus dans un marché dans
lequel le prix de l'électricité atteint
en ce moment 800 euros du mégawattheures
sur les projections trimestrielles et le
prix du gaz entre 150 et 200 euros du
mégawattheure
il y a des des évolutions qui sont qui
peuvent être directement négocié par la
crue auprès du collège des régulateurs
et de l' agence européenne je pense par
exemple à la fixer sion du prix plafond
spot de l'électricité
nous avons eu un épisode
un temps sans fin un épisode
exceptionnel le 4 avril dernier avec un
prix plafond de l'électricité qui
atteint 3000 euros en france pendant
deux heures et qui a un impact sur la
fixation du prix plafond européen
puisque le prix plafond européen s'est
automatiquement décaler vers le haut et
qu'il est passé à 4000 euros ce mode de
fixation automatique est inflationniste
doit changer et j'y serai attaché dans
la négociation avec les régulateurs
européens
si ma candidature est retenue on peut
aussi imaginer de fixer un prix plafond
du prix du gaz qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui qui permettraient de
sécuriser les marchés au delà de ça il
paraît clair maintenant qu'il est
nécessaire de trouver d'autres
mécanismes pour délier les prix de gros
des prix de détail il n'est pas normal
il n'est plus acceptable que le prix de
détail en france d'électricité pour le
client final dépendent à ce point du
prix du gaz sur le marché européen nous
devons mieux intégrer dans notre prix de
marché national la part des énergies
décarbonées renouvelables et nucléaires
qui sont une base pour nous aidons les
prix n'augmentent pas aussi vite que les
prix du gaz ça fait partie des grands
éléments de la discussion à avoir avec
bruxelles en ce qui concerne la reine je
pense là aussi qu'on arrive à la limite
du mécanisme ce mécanisme a fonctionné
quand il a été créé il a pour objectif
de permettre à tous les consommateurs
que ce soit des consommateurs
individuels que ce soit des entreprises
ou des collectivités locales d'ailleurs
de bénéficier de l'énergie nucléaire au
juste prix
mais maintenant les tensions sont trop
importantes et le prix n'était plus
juste vous avez relevés de prix qui
était à 42 euros et qui est passé à 49
points 5 dans les textes que vous venez
d'adopter c'était indispensable
et en ce qui concerne les volumes 120
térawattheures me paraît effectivement
être un maximum dans la période d'autant
plus que nous connaissons cette tension
sur la fourniture d'électricité
nucléaire suite au problème de corrosion
sous contraintes que rencontrent edf
comme la reine protège le consommateur
il est clair qu'il faut maintenant
passer au mécanisme d'après la reine de
toutes façons s'arrête en 2025 il faudra
négocier avec la commission européenne à
la fois l'évolution de la reine et
l'évolution du mode de fixation des
tarifs réglementés
parce que les tarifs réglementés
eux-mêmes dans leur mode de calcul par
empilement sont extrêmement sensibles à
la reine et du coup chaque écrêtement de
la reine a un impact sur la fixation des
tarifs réglementés et on a vu avec les
boucliers en gaz et en électricité qu on
a finalement été capable de protéger le
consommateur avec des mécanismes
excédant les mécanismes classiques
darren est tarifs réglementés et il me
semble que cette question sera posée de
nouveau au législateur et à l'exécutif
pour la protection 2023 pour 2023
le seul élément sur la table aujourd'hui
c'est la communication récente de la
creux proposant une augmentation des
tarifs de 3 9%
au 1er août proposition qui évidemment
n'a pas été retenu par l'exécutif et le
législateur puisque le bouclier a été
posée pour la totalité de l'année 2022
pour 2023 il n'y a pas de chiffres sur
la table mais bien sûr ce sera à la
creuse de faire les simulations et de et
de poser poser les éléments sur la table
quand on y verra plus clair un petit peu
plus tard à l'automne la troisième
priorité c'est bien sûr le développement
des énergies renouvelables l'a cru au
père les appels d'offres pour répondre à
la question je pense qu'on a à la fois
besoin des appels d'offres et besoin de
développer des opérations de gré à gré
qui ne sont plus soutenues par des
subventions publiques
les charges de cs besson néanmoins en
train de baisser très fortement puisque
la contribution cspe qui était très
élevé dans les années précédentes est
maintenant en train de devenir négative
compte tenu des prix de marché de
l'électricité et donc et prix auquel
énergies renouvelables peut être vendu
et je suis favorable à toutes les
mesures de simplification et de
souplesse y compris sur les sur les prix
de vente qui ont été adoptées récemment
sur tous ces sujets je voudrais insister
sur leur importance particulière en
corse et dans nos outre-mer la creux un
rôle important pour raconter à nier la
définition des ppe dans les zones non
interconnectées en particulier en corse
et en outre-mer et pour soutenir le
développement des renouvelables et
l'autonomie énergétique dans ces
territoires ces territoires sont
confrontés à des situations encore plus
difficile que les territoires de france
continentale c'est le rôle de la creuse
les accompagner et je suis très attaché
à cet accompagnement est à la solidarité
nationale qui doit s'exprimer entre tous
nos territoires y compris nos
territoires ultramarins
dans les sujets qui me paraissent
également important que vous avez cités
continuer à soutenir le développement de
l'hydrogène bas carbone à la fois en
solutions de stockage et une solution
pour nos industriels que cet hydrogène
soit produit à partir d'énergies
renouvelables ou qu'il soit par qu'il
soit produit à partir de nucléaire
pour pour finir en espérant avoir
répondu à vos questions avant de
continuer la discussion je voudrais
insister sur deux points d'abord le rôle
européen très important de la creuse la
creuse est à la fois un acteur propre
sur les pouvoirs de régulation pour
obtenir les flexibilité nécessaire de l'
agence européenne de la régulation
lasserre et travailler en bonne
intelligence avec ses collègues au sein
du collège des régulateurs et bien sûr
travailler avec la commission européenne
et puis dire que si je suis présidente
de la cre eux je serais à disposition et
dans un travail en grande proximité
autant avec le législateur qu avec
l'exécutif j'ai travaillé avec vous à de
nombreuses reprises je pense qu'il est
extrêmement important que la crevette sa
capacité d' expertise sa capacité d
analyse sa capacité de simulation au
service du législateur à l'assemblée
comme au sénat c'est ce qu'elle a fait
dans les années précédentes avec
beaucoup d'auditions et aussi des
rencontres à chaque fois que c'était
souhaité et je le dis à monsieur le
président du groupe nrj mais je le dire
à madame la présidente de la commission
et à toutes les sénatrices et où les
sénateurs intéressé je serai à
disposition avec les équipes de la
creuse pour travailler sur les
différentes hypothèses
éclairer les choix que vous aurez à
faire qu'ils vont poser les bases de la
nouvelle politique énergétique du pays
voilà les quelques éléments que je
voulais présenter à l'appui de cette
candidature je regarde brièvement en
vérifiant que je n'ai rien oublié dans
les questions
si peut-être juste la fin des tarifs
réglementés pour le gaz elle a été elle
est posée c'est une règle et je pense
que c'est extrêmement important que la
crue accompagne les consommateurs
l'information et des choix éclairés des
consommateurs vous avez renforcer cette
partie là dans les textes en discussion
actuellement en général sur
l'information des consommateurs et la
capacité du consommateur à faire des
choix éclairés c'est une des missions
importantes de la creux et j'y serai
très attaché je vous remercie très bien
merci beaucoup madame la ministre je
vais donner la parole à mes collègues
qui sont nombreux il faut juste qu'on
est en tête qu'on a une heure à peu près
pour l'ensemble des questions je vais
commencer par jean claude tissot et
ensuite jean pierre moga merci madame la
présidente
j'aurai deux principales questions
madame parent dont
l'une sur le marché européen de
l'énergie et la deuxième sur les
relations entre le gouvernement et la
cre eux le 26 octobre 2021 lors du
consistoire d'un conseil extraordinaire
des ministres européens de l'énergie
vous avez déclaré à propos du marché
européen de l'électricité
nous avons aussi besoin de revoir ces
mécanismes de fonctionnement ça
nécessite une analyse approfondie
approfondie parce que pour l'instant le
prix final facturé au consommateur
d'électricité est extrêmement dépendante
du prix marginal d'énergie et des
énergies fossiles en tout en partageant
votre constat j'aurais souhaité avoir
des éléments de précisions sur les
modifications que vous souhaiteriez vous
l'avez abordé dans votre peau dans votre
discours liminaire que vous souhaiteriez
apporter au marché européen
d'électricité selon vous comment la
creux peut-elle participer à cette
indispensable
réorganisation du marché européen au
marché de l'énergie pardon mais surtout
comment comment vous avez dit qu'il
fallait qu'elle qu'une réorganisation
mais finalement comment vous vous
imaginez cette réorganisation c'est ce
qui est intéressant
et justement ne serait-il pas nécessaire
de prendre du recul sur les logique
uniquement financière et spéculative qui
nuisent à mon sens au bon fonctionnement
de la positionnement d'énergie à des
tarifs raisonnables et à la nécessité et
la nécessaire transition énergétique ma
deuxième question est un peu plus
politique complètement politique mais
elle a son importance pour l'autorité
administrative indépendante que vous
souhaitez président est alors que jean
françois carenco votre potentiel
prédécesseur est devenu ministre du
gouvernement actuel et que vous êtes
vous même une ex mitri une ex ministre
de ce même gouvernement nous avons
l'impression
me trompe que la creuse est devenu une
sorte d'antichambre de la majorité
présidentielle ainsi comment alors vous
l'avez expliqué aussi un dans votre dos
est lé premier vos premiers propos
comment vous percevez
comment percevez vous les relations de
la creux avec l'exécutif justement merci
madame
malte sursaute jean pierre moga ensuite
micheline jacques merci madame la
présidente madame là la ministre aux
côtés de mes collègues les sénateurs
grumier mission j'ai récemment de
travailler sur deux rapports le premier
portant sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de notre pays et le
second sur la relance nucléaire je pense
ne trahir personne en a fait à en
affirmant que la logique que nous avons
retenu dans ses travaux la logique a dit
yves prônée par rte c'est à dire
consistant à marcher sur deux jambes
d'abord une jambe nucléaire d'une part
alors par rapport au nucléaire je pense
que vous avez déjà répondu à mes
mes interrogations sur le rôle de la
creuse j'avais aussi une inquiétude je
ne le cache pas sur votre position
personnelle le par rapport au nucléaire
mais considère que vous avez déjà
répondu et et vous m'avez à rassurer
maintenant je voulais pas vous parler de
la deuxième jambe le renouvelable j'ai
porté là-aussi avec le président de la
commission du développement durable jean
françois longeot une proposition de
résolution relative à la révolte à isme
qui préconise notamment de sortir la
grille volta isme des appels d'offres
solaires innovantes qui ont été lancés
en 2016 pour être intégré dans une
famille dédié de la creuse afin
d'accélérer le développement des projets
au delà des seuls appels d'offres de la
creuse comment comptez vous accompagner
le déploiement le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables dans notre pays
et plus particulièrement ceux liés à la
grille volta isme je vous remercie
merci jean pierre micheline jacques mais
ensuite daniel merci madame la
présidente madame le ministre bon vous
avez répondu en partie à ma question
étant la seule commissaire ultramarines
donc ma question porte sur l'ensemble
des territoires ultramarins
vous le savez votre prédécesseur
jean-françois carenco a veillé à
préserver la péréquation tarifaire tout
temps pagnon l'élaboration des ppn des
collectivités outre mer dont le contexte
de renchérissement du prix des énergies
fossiles
quels principes présideront à votre
action dans les aînés zoo et ni pardon à
saint-barthélemy par exemple l'opérateur
historique est contraint de renouveler
les moteurs vieillissant en les
remplaçant par des moteurs moins
polluants mais à combustion fossile les
retards ou les difficultés de mise en
oeuvre de la transition énergétique
pourrait-il être des facteurs de remise
en cause de cette péréquation
merci micheline daniel manse bernard bus
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
dans sa délibération du 13 juillet 2022
la cre eux indique que la recette
prévisionnelle liés aux énergies
renouvelables électriques s'élève au
titre de 2022 2023 à 8,6 milliards
d'euros pour le budget de l'état sur
cette recette de 8,6 milliards +2 7
milliard sont liés à l'éolien terrestre
cela représente donc une contribution
très intéressante aux finances publiques
la creuse demande donc dans cette
délibération d'accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
vous en avez déjà un petit peu parlé je
voudrais savoir quelle sera vraiment le
rôle de la creuse dans dans cette
accélération
et puis votre position sur le scénario
100% renouvelable de rte dans votre
propos liminaire vous l'avez déjà un
petit peu exposé en creux pour faire un
petit jeu de mots mais j'aimerais bien
avoir votre position précise sur cette
opportunité puisque la faisabilité et
bien et bien indiqués je vous remercie
merci daniel bernard bouix ensuite
dominique estrosi sassone
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la cour des comptes a publié en
juin 2022 un rapport sur l'organisation
des marchés de l'électricité afin de
faire face à la volatilité des prix de
l'énergie l'une des recommandations de
la cour et de redéfinir la méthode de
calcul de la composante des tarifs le
monte de ventes liées à l'écrêtement de
la redd sujets qui vous a bien occupé
sur le projet de loi pouvoir d'achat en
allongeant la période de référence aussi
madame verrons comment entendez vous
mettre en oeuvre cette recommandation de
la creuse merci merci bernard dominique
estrosi sassone ensuite franck montaugé
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre de rapides questions qui
tournent autour du paquet ajustements 55
européen est ce qui ne devrait pas
accorder une plus grande attention à la
neutralité technologique
car les énergies renouvelables sont
clairement favorisé au détriment de
l'énergie nucléaire ou du gaz bas
carbone or l'approvisionnement en
énergie des logements en france est
aujourd'hui très largement réalisée à
partir de l'énergie nucléaire ou des
réseaux de gaz ou de chaleur ne
faudrait-il pas mieux tenir compte du
mix énergétique des états membres la
définition de leur mix énergétique
relève de leur compétence souveraine
et puis une deuxième question est ce que
le paquet ajustements 55 ne pourrait-il
pas être mieux proportionnée au contexte
de crise énergétique européenne car il a
été élaboré dans un contexte qui était
antérieure à la guerre en ukraine
naturellement il ne s'agit pas du tout
de renoncer à l'objectif de baisse de 55
% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'ici 2030 mais pourquoi ne pas donner
plus de souplesse aux états membres et
aux acteurs économiques
merci dominique franck montaugé ensuite
martin berti merci madame la présidente
merci madame vargo
j'aurais plusieurs questions vous avez
vous avez évoqué l'après arènes
dit la nécessité de de revoir notamment
les tarifs réglementés
est ce que vous pourriez aller plus loin
en nous expliquant sur quel principe
vous restructurez riez les tarifs
réglementés et en particulier est ce que
vous avez en tête
de les asseoir sur les coûts complets du
système électrique à long terme est
entendue qu'aujourd'hui ils sont ils
sont structurés sur la base des coûts
marginaux et du coût marginal du
dernier moyenne de production appelée
première première question quelles
réformes par ailleurs du market design
européenne en matière d'électricité
porteriez vous en qualité de présidente
de la creuse ce sujet très très très
très technique très compliqué quand on y
rentre dedans je veux savoir quelle
somme aux orientations et vous idée sur
le sur le sur le sujet en matière de gaz
et de transport de gaz il est possible
que nous nous retrouvions dans une
situation où les infrastructures
existantes
transit transportent moins de gaz que ça
n'a été le cas aujourd'hui donc je
voudrais savoir si dans cette commande
dans cette hypothèse
vous prenez en compte ceux qu'on appelle
les coûts échoué de ses infrastructures
c'est un gros sujet et je pense qu'il ya
des milliards qui sont en jeu derrière
cette question là et dernière question
quel est votre analyse du rôle et des et
des postures de la serre et quel lien
comptez-vous tissés entre l'unss eau
électricité lance au gaz les assauts et
dans les réseaux de coopération des
opérateurs de transport électricité et
gaz au niveau au niveau européen en tout
cas leur représentation voilà je vous
remercie
merci franck martin berthet ensuite
evelyne renou garabédian oui merci
madame la présidente madame wargon
j'aurais de questions à la fois notre
souveraineté industrielle et la
nécessité pour les industriels de
décarbonés leur production demandent une
adaptation des réseaux voir des
créations de façon réactive pour un
approvisionnement en biogaz et ou en
hydrogène bas carbone que prévoyez vous
pour cette mise en oeuvre est ma
deuxième question porte sur l'effacement
par les particuliers y aura-t-il des
retours un retour des contrats types jp
quelle confiance des ménages puisque
actuellement ces contrats à leur font
payer très cher l'électricité
quel retour à une base plus juste pour
ces derniers
merci martin avant evelyne si tu permets
budget oublier hamel dans l'ordre donc
amel gacquerre ensuite eveline pardon et
b merci madame la présidente ma question
porte sur le volet sobriété énergétique
que vous avez évoquées notamment l'auto
consommation individuelle et collective
d'électricité qui permet donc de
produire son électricité et de la
consommer au bon moment avec la baisse
des coûts de production des
installations à partir de ressources
renouvelables et la hausse du prix de
l'électricité
c'est une pratique un mode de
consommation local qui se développe
fortement
pardon et doit être amenée à se
développer davantage à aujourd'hui 150
mille francs son recours à
l'autoconsommation solaire selon rte
selon une étude de la dance et 60% des
français qui seraient intéressés
particulièrement dans le contexte de
crise énergétique que nous connaissons
l'auto consommation représente une
énergie locale particulièrement
intéressante elle apporte une réponse
bien sûr à notre nécessaire indépendance
énergétique à l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité tout en réduisant
l'empreinte écologique quel est votre
point de vue sur ce mode de consommation
et comment comptez-vous intensifier
cette production locale
merci merci à mal avec mes excuses
evelyne renault garabédian pardon
ensuite alain cadec
merci madame la présidente enfin 2021 12
réacteurs nucléaires sur 56 étaient à
l'arrêt alors qu'il s'agit
vraisemblablement du moment du moment où
nous en avons le plus besoin quel est le
rôle de la commission de régulation la
matière et comment baisser l'incertitude
sur la capacité d'edf à remettre en
service des centrales avant cet hiver
merci
merci beaucoup evelyne alain cadec
ensuite patricia chine âgées
oui bergon ma question caractère plutôt
politique
vous parler d'indépendance vous avez
parlé d'indépendance
moi ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est
quelle sera votre position
un dur ou à ma connaissance
je vous êtes présidente du conseil
national
de territoire de progrès
qui est à ma connaissance également
composantes de la majorité
présidentielle
donc est-ce que vous allez continuer
cette responsabilité et qui pourrait
évidemment vous vous posez des problèmes
de
comment dire de compatibilité et de
conflits d'intérêts donc je veux savoir
quelle va être votre jeu l'imaginent
mais où le confirmez vous même
merci alain
patricia synergie ensuite le rend ce
manque et merci madame présidente madame
la ministre dans un contexte de tension
énergie et de dérèglement climatique
nous devons poursuivre la
diversification de mix énergétique
nucléaire et énergies renouvelables se
complète je m'intéresse plus
particulièrement à l'éolien de en mer
pourriez vous nous dresser un bilan des
premiers projets français merci
merci patricia joue alain bondir
sociale laurent laurent saumon et
ensuite jean baptiste lemoyne oui mais
là la présidente mme la ministre
se réjouit je dirais de la mue que vous
avez fait sur le rôle de l'énergie
nucléaire et nous sommes tous convaincus
effectivement de la nécessité d'un mix
énergétique mais compte tenu de la
faiblesse des certaines infrastructures
de transport électricité
quelle est votre vision vous avez dit
qu'il fallait vraiment parlé avec
l'exécutif par l'eec le législatif mais
quelle est votre vision territoriale du
développement des er notamment puisque
il y a
quick quel sera le langage vous allez
prendre avec les territoires sur la
méthanisation sur l'éolien sur la
révolte photovoltaïsme ainsi que sur
l'hydroélectricité
merci beaucoup laurent jean baptiste
lemoyne ensuite anne catherine loisier
merci beaucoup présidente un petit mot
puisque effectivement la creuse à
l'oeuvre aussi au bénéfice des
consommateurs c'est dans un certain
nombre de missions qui lui sont
assignées de veiller à ce qu'ils
obtiennent le meilleur service qu'il
paye le juste prix et donc ma question
c'était justement quel est votre
quels sont vos axes pour mettre l'accent
sur cette dimension
consumériste en termes d'information
parce que l'accès à l'information est
également primordial et puis également
dans le fonctionnement d'une instance
importante qui est le cordis pour régler
un certain nombre de litiges voilà
merci monsieur le ministre anne
catherine loisier ensuite sylviane noël
merci madame est présente en fait moi je
voulais revenir sur vos propos
concernant la csp qui deviendrait
négative donc en ces temps de
problématiques de pouvoir d'achat
s'agissant d'une taxe qui représente
pratiquement 20% de la facture
d'électricité je voulais savoir si on
pourrait envisager une diminution du
coût de la csp merci merci anne
catherine sylviane noël ensuite serge
mérillou merci madame la présidente
madame annie ce sera souhaité connaître
votre opinion sur l'ouverture des à la
concurrence des barrages
hydroélectriques
on a une certaine pression qui nous est
mis par les instances européennes depuis
plusieurs années et j'aurais souhaité
vous entendre sur ce sujet ce jour merci
merci sylviane serge mérillou madame la
ministre madame la présidente vous avez
largement évoqué des pistes à cinq ans
à court terme pour les différentes
énergies moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
savoir si vous avez des perspectives à
plus long terme parce que sur l'énergie
on se projette à 10 20 30 ans et je vous
ai pas entendu sur sur ces pistes là
alors je sais que c'est pas simple mais
moi je voudrais vraiment à savoir un
petit peu plus sur ce point là et puis
sur l'arène
vous l'avez évoqué je suis pas sûr que
la rn est rempli ce qu'on attendait
d'elle c'est à dire permettre à des
opérateurs alternatifs de développer des
solutions de production parce
qu'aujourd'hui la reine c'est une
machine à enrichir des internes des
opérateurs alternatifs et je ne suis pas
sûr c'est protéger sa et protéger les
consommateurs voilà puis j'avais une
question sur l'énergie hydraulique aussi
auquel je suis comme beaucoup
particulièrement attaché est votre
position par rapport donc à la
commission européenne sur ce dossier de
l'hydraulique
merci très bien ça collège je ne vois
pas d'autres questions dont je vais me
permettre de vous opposer moi même
quelques-unes peut-être pour aller dans
le sens de notre collègue serge mérillou
les hypothèses aujourd'hui de besoins en
énergie sont fait effectivement par la
crue pourtant elles sont chalenge et
tous les jours on a l'impression que
l'électrification de nos usages de notre
industrie l'industrie 4.0 la volonté
évidemment de ne pas de ne pas émettre
de gaz à effet de serre et de particules
20 dans le sens d'une accélération
croissante j'allais dire au delà même
des prévisions qui sont faites par la
creuse donc peut-être voir votre vision
à vous sur ce besoin en énergie sûre sur
notre pays deuxième question qui
concerne l'hydrogène verts c'est un
sujet aussi souvent évoqué dans nos
débats
qu'elle quel mode de production
envisagée vous quels investissements
pensez vous qu'il est nécessaire de
faire bien sûr pour produire mais aussi
pour stocker pour transporter il ya là
un enjeu majeur au moment où par
ailleurs l'europe met beaucoup d'argent
sur la recherche et développent man en
matière de production d'hydrogène je
voudrais revenir également sur le
nucléaire quelques instants vous nous
avez fait une profession de foi pour le
pour le nucléaire mais au-delà de cette
profession de foi quels projets
industriels voyez vous pour la france
quelles sont les investissements
nécessaires comment voyez vous le rôle
évidemment d'edf faut-il avoir d'autres
partenaires comment voyez-vous le
problème d'eau rano le problème des
déchets etc de l'approvisionnement en
combustible
et enfin dernière question un petit peu
différente que qui a été évoqué par l'un
de nos collègues c'est comment voyez
vous la place des collectivités
territoriales dans le développement des
énergies renouvelables
nous savons que l'acceptabilité sociale
est presque démocratique est un enjeu
majeur pour notre pays est ce pour vous
les élus locaux sont ils une source de
soucis et de freins ou une source
d'opportunité je vous donne déjà la
réponse dans la question
voilà madame la ministre de nombreuses
questions vous laisse peut-être quelques
instants par ce que font un peu
d'organisation sûr
merci beaucoup madame la présidente et
merci beaucoup surtout mesdames des
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs
pour toutes ces questions je vais
essayer d'y répondre dans l'ordre de
façon exhaustive donc monsieur le le
sénateur tissot vous m'avez demandé ma
vision du marché européen de l'énergie
quelles sont les modifications
y apporter et comment la crue peut y
participer
je pense qu'ils ont nés au moment où il
faut qu'on fasse évoluer la vision
européenne de ce qu'est un marché qui
fonctionne bien à l'échelle européenne
il faut le garder ce qui marche garder
ce qui marche c'est le fait de pouvoir
être selon les cas exportateurs ou
importateurs vous le savez en
électricité la france est exportatrice
nette en général elle n'a été encore les
dans la dernière période mais elle est
importatrice de plus en plus souvent je
crois 80 jours importatrice l'année
dernière et donc nous avons aussi besoin
d'un marché dans lequel l'électricité
circule au sens propre du terme pour
être en capacité d'assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
néanmoins le mode de fixation du prix
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui l'appel au
coût marginal de la dernière centrale
appelé le dernier lieu de production
appelée dans sa manière de se répercuter
du marché de gros aux marchés de détail
exposé énormément les consommateurs
qu'ils soient individuels ou industriels
à cette volatilité des prix et d'une
certaine manière c'est probablement dans
le lien différent entre le prix de gros
est le prix de détail que une réforme
est apportée comment la cre peut y
participer
essentiellement avec un rôle d'
expertise danalyse et d' influence
puisque ce sont des négociations entre
ministres de l'énergie se sont ensuite
des textes et l'un d'entre vous a
rappelé que le mix énergétique est un
élément de souveraineté nationale c'est
absolument exact ce sont des décisions
nationales même si il y a une influence
communautaire la creuse a aussi un rôle
extrêmement important pour faire des
simulations puisqu'en fonction des
scénarii envisagés la croupe simuler
l'impact sur les tarifs et sur les prix
de détail est donc éclairé la décision
sur votre deuxième question qui était
est ce une antichambre de la majorité
présidentielle je souhaite vraiment
répondre non je crois que mon
prédécesseur a montré son indépendance
dans ses différentes de prises de
positions y compris récente et vous
savez que ce n'est pas mon cas que
c'était un avocat de la reine à 150
térawattheures ça n'est pas mon cas je
le dit extrêmement clairement je ne
pense pas que la reine doit être fixée
au delà de 120 je pense que 120 est un
vrai maximum donc il avait lui-même sa
liberté d'analysé d'esprit donc je vous
le redis je souhaite exercer ses
fonctions en toute indépendance et ça
permet de répondre tout de suite à la
question du sénateur cadec bien sûr je
démissionnerai de la présidence du
conseil national de territoire de
progrès
c'est tout à fait normal puisque je
pense que ça n'est pas compatible
quelles que soient les textes avec
l'exercice d'une fonction de président
d'une autorité administrative
indépendante et donc ça m'amènera je
voulais dis très clairement a tourné
cette page de la politique et à ouvrir
une page nouvelle au service de mon pays
les monsieur sénateurs moga et oui je
pense vraiment qu'il faut qu'on marche
sur deux jambes le nucléaire d'un côté
et les énergies renouvelables de l'autre
et je crois vraiment comme que c'est
comme ça maintenant que se pose
l'équation énergétique du pays la
troisième jambe si vous me permettez
cette figure maladroite étant la baisse
de la consommation à la fois à travers
la sobriété et l'efficacité énergétique
je crois que ce sont vraiment les
piliers de notre politique je pense
qu'effectivement pour les nerfs et en
particulier pour la grille volteis mais
il faut peut-être trouver des mécanismes
un peu plus spécifique que les appels
d'offres classique et ça ça mène aussi à
répondre à certaines interrogations la
vôtre madame la présidente je crois que
la réponse était un peu dans la question
et d'autres d'autres questions sur les
relations que les collectivités
territoriales elles sont indispensables
elles sont indispensables sur tous les
sujets les collectivités locales sont
des acteurs extrêmement important de
cette transition énergétique et de cette
transition écologique moi je suis fier
quand j'étais secrétaire d'état d'avoir
signé une centaine de contrats de
transition écologique avec des
territoires en général à l'échelle de
l'intercommunalité
pour accompagner ces territoires dans le
développement à la fois écologique et
économique sur la base de leurs propres
projets et je crois qu'il faut vraiment
repartir des projets des territoires en
fait l'arrivée de nerfs le développement
de solutions de stockage ce sont
vraiment des sujets qu'il faut bâtir
tout de suite avec les représentants des
territoires et avec les élus et puis
après sur tous les sujets réseau
distribution que ce soit en transport en
distribution stricto sensu les élus sont
clés la creuse a un rôle important dans
l'âme dans le travail sur les schémas de
raccordement régionaux et locaux de la
méthanisation par exemple pour
l'injection du biogaz donc ça ça fait
partie des sujets sur lesquels il faut
un accord local pour définir quelle est
la meilleure organisation territoriale
pour ce raccordement et donc vous pouvez
compter sur moi pour être dans un
dialogue approfondi avec les
collectivités territoriales
madame la sénatrice jacques vous vous
avez rappelé la question des territoires
ultramarins
vous avez raison mais je les dis dans
mon propos introductif je suis très
attaché la péréquation tarifaire
c'est l'expression de notre solidarité
nationale vis-à-vis des territoires
ultra marins mais aussi de la corse et
des autres et dénis donc j'y suis très
attaché même si les coûts de production
sont importants on en outre-mer ils sont
importants parce que les contraintes
sont plus importantes et que les les
infrastructures ont besoin d'être
transformés mais elles ne peuvent être
transformés que progressivement donc une
loi a fixé un objectif ambitieux de
développement des renouvelables en
outre-mer et d'atteindre l'autonomie
énergétique en outre-mer en 2037 un
objectif qui sera difficile à tenir je
pense qu'il faut accompagner la
trajectoire ça revient un peu au point
avec les élus locaux c'est territoire
par territoire et ppe par ppe qu' il
faut définir ses trajectoires et ensuite
une fois que cette trajectoire est dans
la ppe défini avec les collectivités
territoriales
alors la solidarité nationale finance à
travers la cspe et je suis extrêmement
attachée
monsieur le sénateur salmon vous m'avez
posé la question de la recette de cspe
qui a effectivement très importante
actuellement en fait les choses se sont
inversées la csp a été une charge pour
le budget de l'état maintenant compte
tenu du prix de l'énergie aujourd'hui la
cspe devient une recette pour le budget
de l'état
et ça me permet d'ailleurs de répondre
anne catherine loisier là dessus en fait
maintenant la cspe est déconnecté de la
facture du consommateur la facture du
consommateur c'est la tei cfe et 7 et
icf feu a été abaissé à 1 euros du
mégawattheures dans le cadre du bouclier
tarifaire pour 2022 et donc la question
se posera en plf 2023 de savoir comment
positionner cet isf feu et ça c'est une
décision de puissance publique puisque
c'est une décision du budget de l'état
mais en tout cas c'est plus acceptable
par le budget de l'état si je peux dire
dans la mesure où la cspe elle-même a
maintenant une contribution positive et
donc il faut continuer à développer ses
nerfs à la fois sur l'éolien terrestre
et sur l'éolien en mer c'était la
question de patricia chez danger
est donc là creux un rôle important elle
a un rôle à travers les appels d'offres
elle a aussi un rôle à travers le
pilotage des guichets elle a un rôle sur
la capacité à accompagner les contrats
de gré à gré je pense que ce qu'on
appelle les ppa je pense que c'est un
outil utile qui peut se développer et
sécurisée des approvisionnements à long
terme et puis en ce qui concerne le
scénario 100% renouvelable rtl ce
scénario est sur la table mais il est
aussi sur la table avec un certain
nombre de réserves moi je pense qu'on a
besoin des deux je pense qu'on a besoin
de nerfs et de nucléaire donc je suis
plutôt en faveur des scénarios qui
propose un mix entre les nerfs et le
nucléaire mais ça c'est un sujet qui
vous sera posée en tant que législateur
lors de la loi sur la ppe ce scénario
existe mais il dit aussi qu'il est
extrêmement exigeant notamment sur les
conditions de stockage qui mène à la
question de l'hydrogène qui est une
question qui est absolument je pense
vital pour le pays
monsieur le sénateur but vous m'avez
posé la question sur le rapport de la
cour des comptes sur l'organisation du
marché et ses préconisations il ya
effectivement deux préconisations direct
pour la creule une qui est de rendre
public le mode de calcul des coûts
complets sur l'énergie nucléaire et j'y
suis favorable et la deuxième qui est de
faire évoluer le mode de calcul de la
répartition de la reine et donc de
l'impact sur les terres vieux pour
prendre une période de référence plus
longues ce qui a comme avantage de
limiter un peu la volatilité et donc de
limiter un peu la transmission des prix
de marché de gros aux consommateurs à
travers les tarifs réglementés de vente
de l'électricité j'y suis favorable donc
la croatie s'y emploiera si ma
candidature est retenue madame la
sénatrice estrosi sassone vous m'avez
posé la question sur l'impact sur du
paquet fit for fifty five et la
nécessité de tenir compte du mix
énergétique des pays je crois que c'est
effectivement très important la
commission européenne nous fixe et le
conseil européen se fixe des objectifs
extrêmement ambitieux mais après c'est à
chaque pays de définir sa trajectoire à
partir de son histoire et à partir de
ces moyens de production et nous avons
la chance de nous appuyer sur un parc
nucléaire j'en ai parlé sur un parc
d'hydroélectricité je voudrais y venir
maintenant et sur des nerfs en
développement et donc il faut faire
attention à cette neutralité à l'échelle
européenne je pense qu'on a eu une belle
victoire avec l'intégration du nucléaire
dans la taxonomie verte européenne un
sujet sur lequel va qui était
extrêmement important pour l'avenir de
notre filière et de nos industries et
notre souveraineté énergétique donc je
pense que c'est en ce sens qu'il faut
travailler puis votre deuxième question
était de mieux proportionné tout ça au
contexte de crise et c'est vrai que le
contexte de crise d'un côté nous pousse
à accélérer d'une certaine manière à
sortir du gaz quand c'est possible à
aller vers la sobriété et vers tous les
mécanismes de flexibilité qui je pense
peut être encore plus utilisé effacement
interruptible it et mécanismes de
capacité et de l'autre il faut qu'on
soit pragmatique et je crois que c'est
ce qu'on fait aussi avec ce terminal
flottant méthanier au large du havre qui
nous permet de sécuriser nos
approvisionnements il faut qu'on soit en
capacité de maîtriser nous mêmes notre
destin énergétique
monsieur sénateurs montaugé sur la prêt
à rennes on c'est un sujet sur lequel l'
expertise a commencé mais n'est pas
encore n'est pas encore complètement
consolidée c'est un sujet qui arrivent
pour 2025
en fait il me semble que nous devons
concilier deux objectifs
le premier c'est de permettre à edf de
financer les investissements nécessaires
sur le nucléaire actuelle est donc de
permettre à edf de de couvrir dans de
bonnes conditions de marché c'est
complet du nucléaire et donc de partir
du coût complet du nucléaire et le
deuxième bien sûr et d'assurer la
concurrence sur le marché français est
de permettre à
du nucléaire de l'hydroélectricité des
sujets sur lesquels eux oui du site du
système énergétique et de l'autre
permettre aux consommateurs de
bénéficier de l'investissement qui a été
fait à la fois par les consommateurs
mais surtout par les contribuables dans
notre système énergétique actuelle est
donc permettre à tous les consommateurs
d'y avoir accès lorsqu'il décide de
choisir un fournisseur alternatif je
reconnais tout à fait ça a été dit par
l'un d'entre vous que la reine n'a pas
atteint l'un des objectifs qui lui
avaient été fixés à l'époque qui était
de favoriser le développement par les
fournisseurs alternatifs de moyens de
production et on voit que ça ne s'est
pas produit je vous le disais dans mon
propos introductif la première chose à
faire à mon avis du point de vue de la
crue à très court terme est vraiment de
renforcer la surveillance sur la manière
dont la reine dont bénéficient les
fournisseurs alternatifs la reine
actuelle est bien intégralement
transmise au consommateur
pour que ça ne soit pas une rente des
fournisseurs alternatifs mais que le
consommateur final s'ils retrouvent que
ce soit un consommateurs industriels ou
un consommateur individuel dans le prix
de vente puisque la reine est fait au
bénéfice du consommateur final et
sûrement pas au bénéfice des
fournisseurs pour la suite il faut donc
je pense repartir de la couverture des
coûts complets en trouvant un mécanisme
qui permet de faire bénéficier du
système énergétique
tous les consommateurs c'est donc
probablement plutôt de l'ordre du prix
régulés que de la reine parce que la
reine est asymétrique c'est l'une de ses
grandes difficultés c'est à dire quand
les prix de l'énergie est élevé des
fêtes obligé de vendre quand le prix de
l'énergie est bas
df
ne vend pas au prix de la reine mais
vend au prix de marché
là je parle de la manière dont on
réguler le prix de cession du nucléaire
par edf après ça ne veut pas forcément
dire qu'il ya des tarifs de vente
réglementée au détail pour tous les
consommateurs puisque il faut permettre
aux consommateurs de continuer à choisir
son fournisseur d'électricité mais dans
un mécanisme de de vente sur les marchés
par edf de son électricité qui lui
permettent de couvrir ses coûts et donc
qu'il ne soit pas au détriment de df ce
qui est le cas aujourd'hui avec la reine
si je continue
sur le market design c'est un peu le
même point
c'est à dire je vous vois réagir moi je
veux bien approfondir la réponse si vous
le souhaitez
excusez moi je sais ma faute c'est
certain je comprends pas ce que vous ne
nous expliquer les couvertures dans tous
les sens là je
je vais essayer d'être plus
je vais essayer d'être plus clair dans
ma réponse
la reine c'est un prix de vente d'edf
aux autres fournisseurs
ce prix de vente d'edf aux autres
fournisseurs à 42 euros du
mégawattheures il est trop bas vous
venez de le relever et par ailleurs il
est calculé il devrait être calculée de
façon à permettre une vraie couverture
des coûts complets du système
énergétique
si on garde un mode de fixation du prix
de vente d'edf de son électricité
historique aux autres fournisseurs
il faut voir comment est ce que dans la
réforme des trv qui est le deuxième
morceau de la réforme des tarifs de
vente sur aux consommateurs
cette cette vente réguler d'edf à ses
fournisseurs se fait au bénéfice du
consommateur ça ne veut pas dire
remettre tous les français soute et
hervé
le marché de l'électricité a été ouvert
la concurrence s'exerce mais ça veut
dire trouver le mode de fixation de ces
tarifs réglementés de vente qui lui-même
intègre ce prix régulés d'edf et après
l'été rvc à peu près deux tiers du
marché mais une bonne partie du reste du
marché est en fait fixée en référence au
terreau vais donc d'une certaine manière
à chaque fois que le trb lui-même et
fixer les tarifs réglementés de vente il
a un impact direct sur les contrats qui
sont juridiquement haute hervé il a un
impact indirect sur tous les prix de
marché donc j'essaye de vous apporter
une réponse en deux temps comment est-ce
qu edf vend son électricité sur le
marché de gros et comment ensuite le
marché des thaï intègre et dans les deux
cas pense qu'il faut qu'on couvre les
coûts d'edf pour permettre à edf de
continuer à maintenir la qualité de sa
production existantes au coût complet et
que de l'autre on trouve les mécanismes
qui permettent au consommateur final
soit vial trv soit via le jeu normal du
marché de bénéficier de cette
électricité à des prix régulés c'est
donc sur deux plans qui me semble que la
réponse peut être apporté dans les
tarifs de afin d'aller dans les coups de
les prix de vente libre on est en
terrain une composante thervay c'est ça
que vous dites
ce que j'ai au nucléaire ce que je dis
c'est que sur le marché libre il y à peu
près deux tiers de particuliers qui sont
hautes hervé et donc pour lequel de prix
est fixé par le terreau v et que
l'immense majorité du reste du marché se
fixe en réalité par référence donc le
trv est central dans la fixation des
prix sur le marché de façon directe ou
façon indirecte je pense qu'il faut
maintenir des trv ça j'en suis
absolument convaincu
vous m'avez aussi posé une question sur
le transport de gaz
c'est effectivement une question très
importante d'abord je pense qu'on n'a
pas encore une très bonne visibilité sur
les volumes potentiels de transport de
gaz notamment avec la montée en charge
du biométhane du biogaz aussi avec la
question de l'hydrogène parce que pour
l'instant nous sommes en train de voler
les expertises collectives est en cours
pour savoir si ces infrastructures
pourraient aussi servir à transporter
d'hydrogène ou pas
mais après il est clair que les coûts
échoué s'il y en a on en a pas pour
l'instant mais s'il devait y en avoir
deux vont être dans l'équation global
tarifaire de financement des réseaux
sous une forme de solidarité ou sous une
autre parce que n'est pas possible de
laisser des gestionnaires de réseaux
faire face tout seul à des coûts qui
sont simplement liés à la transition
énergétique
et enfin sur la serre je pense très
important d'être très présent à la serbe
mon prédécesseur potentiel jean françois
carenco y aller régulièrement l'un des
commissaires il va régulièrement aussi
et puis de ne pas se reposer que sur la
serre et donc de travailler que le
collège des régulateurs le cerf est de
travailler avec les coopérations l'école
et les organismes de coopération des
réseaux vous avez cités lasserre a une
vision très libérale de la régulation
des marchés je pense que c'est important
d'y porter une vision de plus long terme
de protection du consommateur mais aussi
de la souveraineté
sur la question de la souveraineté
industrielle
madame la sénatrice berthet et de
l'adaptation dès réseaux je pense qu'il
ya des endroits dans lesquels il faut
peut-être des investissements
spécifiques dans les très grands bassins
industriels pour être en capacité de
faire les évolutions de réseau soit de
raccordement de nerfs soit de
raccordement d'hydrogène et donc je vous
pourrez imaginer de travailler
spécifiquement avec les grands bassins
industriels pour voir comment est ce que
les réseaux peuvent les soutenir dans
leur développement industriel ou dans la
réindustrialisation sur l'effacement je
pense qu'on a toutes une réflexion à
avoir sur l'évolution des contrats c'est
d'abord une réflexion des fournisseurs
mais je pense que la crue peut avoir un
rôle important on a effectivement des
contrats qui ne sont plus du tout
intéressant pour les particuliers alors
même que ces contrats pourraient être à
la fois à leurs bénéfices et au bénéfice
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement et de
la flexibilité et donc je pense qu'il
faut revoir les tarifs et probablement
proposer des incitations aux
fournisseurs qui sont en capacité de
proposer des offres qui a dit ces deux
objectifs
madame la sénatrice gacquerre sur la
sobriété énergétique
moi je suis favorable à
l'autoconsommation je pense
qu'effectivement c'est à la fois une
attente des français c'est à la fois un
élément qui peut nous aider dans cette
période de flexibilité de sobrier et
sécurité d'approvisionnement
toute la question est une question
délicate et de faire de trouver le juste
point d équilibre entre le développement
de l'auto consommation et la solidarité
nationale sur le financement des réseaux
parce que les réseaux profitent à tous
et donc si on commence à démembrer
morceau par morceau on a après un
problème de solidarité et de pérennité
et péréquation sur les réseaux mais au
fond je pense qu'on peut aller plus loin
sur le soutien à à l'autoconsommation
qui je pense peut être un élément
important
y compris d'ailleurs d'acceptabilité sur
les énergies renouvelables
sur la question de madame la sénatrice
renault garabédian sur l'arrêt des
réacteurs nucléaires là la creuse a pas
un rôle direct ni sur la reine et sur la
reprise évidemment d'activité des
réacteurs nucléaires qui sont sous la
responsabilité de l'opérateur edf est
sous le contrôle de l'asn c'est plutôt
dans le modèle économique dont on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est à dire le
financement à assurer le financement des
coûts complets d'une tenue du nucléaire
actuelle et trouver le modèle de
financement du nouveau nucléaire que la
crue peut avoir un rôle après ça devient
un rôle industriel d'opérateurs et là ça
n'est plus du ressort de la commission
de régulation de l'énergie
monsieur le sénateur cadec je crois
avoir répondu à votre question sur
territoire de progrès
madame la sénatrice chilin j'ai
effectivement l'éolien en mer est un
élément extrêmement important de notre
développement d'énergies renouvelables
notre sécurité d'approvisionnement et de
notre mix énergétique le premier parc
éolien en mer produit enfin il a été
raccordé il est maintenant connectés de
nombreux projets sont en cours je pense
que la creuse a un rôle important
d'accompagnement y compris
l'accompagnement des réseaux puisqu'une
partie des projets éoliens en mer est
une partie du ciel de construction des
projets eux-mêmes une partie et d'éolien
en mer est liée à notre capacité à
raccorder ses éoliennes dans de bonnes
conditions et donc la crue contiendra
continuera pardon à soutenir y compris
avec ses appels d'offres
monsieur le sénateur ce moment sur la
vision territoriale je pensais avoir en
partie répondu mais en complément oui on
n'arrivera pas à développer les énergies
renouvelables si on ne le fait pas en
accord avec les territoires dans une
vision de planification territoriale
parce que c'est extrêmement important
qui donne de la visibilité et de la
capacité à se projeter
parce qu'on voit bien que le
développement au coup par coup pose des
vrais problèmes d'accessibilité et que
nous devons aller plus loin sur
l'hydroélectricité
permet de répondre aux différentes
questions posées moi je suis favorable à
ce qu'il y à une renégociation avec
bruxelles qui nous permet de garder la
maîtrise de nos concessions
hydroélectriques
l'une des hypothèses sur la table et de
l'organiser sous forme une part dont
deux quasi régie qui me semble être une
solution juridique est relativement sur
l'hydroélectricité ça fait partie de
notre sécurité d'approvisionnement ça
fait partie de notre compétitivité ça
fait partie de notre souveraineté
énergétique
la france a depuis longtemps
essayé de mener cette négociation avec
la commission européenne je pense que
cette négociation se ramener aussi suite
à la nationalisation d'edf et aux
modèles à apporter pour edf dans le
futur pour permettre à la fois de
développer de nouveaux nucléaire et de
maintenir nos concessions
hydroélectriques ça ne concerne pas que
des f mais évidemment beaucoup edf dans
des conditions dans lesquelles nous
sommes sûr d'assurer cette souveraineté
monsieur le sénateur lemoine vous avez
tout à fait raison sur l'information du
consommateur je pense que c'est un
élément extrêmement important la qualité
de l'information la qualité de service
la capacité à choisir des offres de
façon éclairée me paraît être un point
très important la crue du travail ali
travaille aussi avec le médiateur de
l'énergie
avec lequel les liens pourraient être
resserrée et quant au corps dit c'est
une institution extrêmement importante
pour traiter des différents qui à ma
connaissance fonctionne bien et qui doit
être soutenu
madame la sénatrice loisirs je crois que
j'ai répondu sur la question sur la
diminution de la cspe madame la
sénatrice noël je crois avoir répondu
sur les barrages hydroélectriques
monsieur le sénateur mérillou
sur les pistes à long terme
il me semble que nous avons une vision
2050 qui se dégage progressivement mais
là aussi ce sera c'est vraiment un
élément de la politique énergétique du
pays donc soumises à l'assemblée au
sénat
l'année qui vient pour moi on est avec
ce double mouvement que je citais tout à
l'heure une baisse de la consommation
d'électricité pardon une baisse de la
consommation d'énergie qu'il faut
absolument qu'on accompagne avec plus
d'efficacité plus de sobriété
c'est aussi ce que j'ai essayé de porter
sur la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments et une évolution de notre mix
énergétique dans lequel on sort
progressivement des énergies fossiles ce
qui suppose plus de production
d'électricité selon les scénarii de rte
on est alors qu'on est aujourd'hui à peu
près à 450 térawatts heure de
consommation d'électricité
on serait autour de 650 à 750 voire 800
en fonction aussi de la
réindustrialisation possible du pays qui
fait partie de nos objectifs
stratégiques donc pour moi les pistes à
moyen terme c'est vraiment cette baisse
de consommation c'est ce changement des
usages c'est cette montée en puissance
d'une aide à l'électricité décarbonés
pour nous permettre d'atteindre les la
neutralité carbone à horizon 2050
sur l'arène on a eu l'occasion d'évoquer
sa dans la discussion précédente je
reconnais vraiment jeu je les dis que la
reine n'a pas atteint cet objectif de
développement des des solutions de
production alternative qui était initial
et qu' il appartient pour le coup
vraiment à la creux de vérifier que la
reine n'est pas un enrichissement des
fournisseurs et sas sas a lieu avec la
surveillance du marché probablement un
renforcement des contrôles de la
fixation des prix des fournisseurs
alternatifs qui bénéficient de la reine
sur l'hydroélectricité je crois avoir
répondu
madame la présidente sur vos questions
sur les hypothèses de besoins
énergétiques ces hypothèses sont plutôt
faite par rte que par la creuse la
creuse fait pas vraiment de scénario
d'hypothèses mais je vous dis moi je me
cale avec l'idée d'une hypothèse de
baisse de la consommation d'énergie à
moyen terme des 2 d'augmentation à la
fois en valeur relative en valeur
absolue de l'électricité dans le mix
média pas que ça il ya la chaleur
renouvelable qui est extrêmement
importante et puis le remplacement
progressif du gaz par par le par le
biométhane
l'hydrogène je sais vous avez été
nombreux et travailler je pense un sujet
extrêmement important on a d'ailleurs eu
négociations en cours sur le bec gazier
dans laquelle il faut absolument que on
obtienne que quel que soit notre mode de
production d'hydrogène des carbonnais je
sais que c'est un point qui vous tient à
coeur que cet hydrogène soit produit à
partir
d'électricité renouvelable ou qu'il soit
produit à partir d'électricité nucléaire
il puisse être soutenue ça je pense que
c'est un point extrêmement important
dans la neutralité des technologies
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne et après
je pense qu'on a encore beaucoup de
travail sur les investissements et sur
les réseaux sur le nucléaire au delà du
soutien à court terme c'est
effectivement tout un projet industriel
avec une filière industrielle à soutenir
notre opérateur national à soutenir et
je pense que la nationalisation
finalement ce sera l'occasion de le
soutenir de façon différente et puis
continuer à travailler sur la fin du
cycle du combustible
j'ai dans mes fonctions précédentes
accompagner le projet
cigéo sur le site de bure qui est un
projet qui est important dans le cadre
de ce bouclage du cycle du combustible
et puis sur les collectivités locales je
crois avoir répondu madame la présidente
merci beaucoup d'enjeux comme il reste
quelques minutes j'ai une petite
question bonus
parce qu'on en a parlé entre eux mêmes
et pas vraiment justement sur la réforme
de df j'aurais voulu avoir votre avis où
nous parle effectivement de
renationalisation
les premiers éléments que nous avons ne
serait ce que dans le projet de loi
rectificatif que nous avons voté
nuitamment hier soir
n'est pas une recapitalisation d'edf
c'est juste la prise de participation
des actionnaires minoritaires
aujourd'hui par l'état
comment est ce que vous voyez
cette réorganisation nécessaire d'edf au
delà même sa direction sa présence
comment est ce que vous voyez edf demain
quelle est votre vision de cet opérateur
qui sera un opérateur donc public
comment est ce qu'il s'insère dans un
univers public privé quel est le poids
quel est le rôle de cet opérateur de sa
structuration de sa stratégie c'est
important pour nous de partager avec
vous peut-être cela
non je pense qu'on a la chance d'avoir
un grand opérateur national edf dont
nous avons besoin pour atteindre les
objectifs initiaux que je citais la
souveraineté et la sécurité
d'approvisionnement la protection des
consommateurs et la transition
écologique
et donc moi je suis favorable au fait
que l'état soit actionnaire à 100% d'edf
qui revient à une forme de
nationalisation
s'opposera ensuite la question de donner
à edf les moyens de sa trajectoire de
long terme moyen pour le soutien du
nucléaire actuel et le grand carénage
qui arrive moyens pour l'investissement
dans le nouveau nucléaire
moyens pour le maintien et le
développement des concessions
hydroélectriques et df reste actionnaire
majoritaire des réseaux qui sont
absolument vitaux pour le pays que ce
soit rte ou aînés 10
edf est donc un acteur incontournable du
marché je pense que nous devons le
soutenir comme un comme un fleuron
national
la crue est évidemment forcément attaché
c'est son rôle à la concurrence sur le
marché
concurrence au bénéfice du consommateur
final que ce soit le consommateur
individuel ou industriels ou d'ailleurs
même des collectivités locales qui elles
aussi ont des factures d'énergie qui
sont pas forcément négligeable et donc
il me paraît sain aussi qu'il ya une
concurrence sur le marché que cette
concurrence puisse s'exercer qui permet
aussi d innovation et c'était le sens de
l'ouverture et peut-être qu'il faut
renforcer la capacité de la concurrence
à fournir vraiment de l'innovation
positive au service des industriels et
des consommateurs donc ça ne place pas à
edf en monopole à 100%
sur la totalité de la chaîne de
production et de vente au détail
d'électricité mais il me semble qu'il
faut assumer d'avoir un opérateur
national de référence qui est celui qui
nous permettra d'atteindre nos grands
objectifs et après sur la réforme plus
précise
je pense qu'on est elle n'est pas encore
dessiné et moi je n'y ai pas
suffisamment travaillé c'est d'ailleurs
pas le rôle de la creuse de la définir
mais en tout cas c'est avec ces
orientations là que je pense qu'il faut
orienter cette réforme
bien y at il
des demandes de prise de parole
supplémentaire ou est pire qu perth
merci madame la présidente
le gouvernement dont vous faisiez partie
a pris l'orientation vu du passé au tout
électrique notamment en matière de
transports est ce que vous pensez qu'il
est raisonnable compte tenu de la
fragilité nos approvisionnements une
autre production d'électricité d'aller
dans ce sens pour 2030 merci du coup la
parole à jean jacques michau puis en
complément de ce que vous avez dit
madame le vous avez dit que et ja suite
à fait d'accord avec ça que la
concurrence n'a pas donné les résultats
escomptés
donc quel type de concurrence à votre
avis pourrait donner les résultats qui
était voulu à l'origine
pour atteindre pour répondre à votre
question monsieur le sénateur pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone on a
absolument besoin de réduire
progressivement l'usagé des énergies
fossiles qui sont d'ailleurs majoritaire
toujours dans le pays aujourd'hui
c'est à dire moins de pétrole moins de
fuel et moins de chardons et donc la
question de la voiture transports elle
se pose forcément comme ça après moi je
suis convaincu que c'est la
diversification qui nous assure de la
résilience face à des crises on en a
vécu des très importante et on ne sait
pas quelles sont les crises qui sont
devant nous diversification ça veut dire
non seulement l'électrification des
voitures mais aussi travailler sur
l'hydrogène par exemple comme dans les
transports peut-être pas sur les
voitures individuelles seulement mais en
tout cas aussi pour les camions et pour
les trains ça veut dire aussi proposé
des mobilités douces et des mobilités
alternatives ça veut dire travailler sur
les biocarburants je pense qu'il faut
qu'on soit pragmatique dans notre
capacité à accompagner tous les choix en
matière de transport qui vont vers la
décarbonation progressive je pense que
la crise actuelle nous apprend
effectivement que nous avons un système
sous tension que nous avons un système
qui peut se trouver en difficulté de
sécurité d'approvisionnement et que donc
nous devons être très vigilants à
travailler dans cette forme de
diversification et puis la deuxième
question c'est sur la concurrence
là pour le coup c'est vraiment le rôle
de la creuse de surveiller les marchés à
la fois de gros et de détail pour
s'assurer que la concurrence se fait
bien au bénéfice du consommateur final
donc c'est le contrôle sur l'évolution
des prix notamment les prix gros pour
vérifier qu a pas de manipulation de
marché c'est le contrôle sur la fixation
des tarifs et des prix de vente au
détail et c'est probablement aussi une
discussion avec les différents
fournisseurs pour voir avec eux à quel
point les offres qu'ils proposent sont
des offres à valeur ajoutée par rapport
à l'offre de référence donc là creux à
la fois un rôle de surveillance elle a
un rôle de gendarme
avec le cas échéant des sanctions à
prendre et probablement aussi un rôle
d'émulation et de dialogues un peu un
peu serré avec les fournisseurs en la
matière forte effectivement de
l'expérience des années précédentes pour
lesquels la simple ouverture n'a pas
forcément permis les innovations
très bien merci beaucoup madame vergon
et bien nous allons vous libérer pour
voilà pour une audition à l'assemblée
nationale
et puis nous même je vous demande de
rester dans la salle puisque nous allons
procéder au vote à bulletin secret merci
beaucoup à tous d'être là parce que je
sais que nombre d'entre vous étaient là
fort tard hier soir